good morning if it's Monday I spent the
weekend back home in Indianapolis
actually got to ride a combine with
Henry and learn about like contemporary
American farming practices from this
amazing farmer named Terry I know
there's a very Midwestern thing it may
not resonate with you Hank but hey I
love corn B I love gigantic machine so
it was like just a dream come true
anyway now I'm back on the paper town
set we're shooting some of the abandoned
mini mall scenes today it looks
incredible I can't show it to you but
I'm I'm so excited here I'll show you a
little bit remember this shirt from our
childhood and speaking of our childhood
so icon Thursday you posted this picture
of us from circa 1981 by the way
significant improvement in my pointing
game now that we're like a weekend pizza
mess in response nerdfighters doing some
photoshopping like us as a rap duo loves
playing cards aw Hank the many gifts of
pizza mess sir fighters if you want to
Photoshop further there is a link in the
doobly-doo okay I have to go back to the
set
sorry the paint a hat Nozick Owen hey
wait our salsa look at that camera have
intense camera envy okay so here's how
90% of my time on set is spent in
between takes I can listen to NAT and
justice and Austin make jokes and
they're always very funny so that's nice
and I watch the monitors which I can't
really show you except for like this and
then after every take there's all these
discussions about like oh should it be
bigger should it be smaller we're
surviving
Oh video bombed so everyone tries to
figure out like how to make the movie
good and then they're like what John
what do you think and I'm like I think
that this is amazing every take is
ridiculously good the camerawork is much
better than in my vlogging the acting is
astonishingly good and then they all go
back to talking about lighting and stuff
so basically I don't really have a job
but I have a chair director Jake
Schreier wears a suit every single day
to set and his shoe game is always
exceptionally strong how's the movie
going are you going super well okay
there you go good you see the way you
say my name is so weird it's like one
syllable hungry yeah the other big thing
that happens on set is that I try to get
advice from people like like
cinematographer David Landsberg taught
me a little bit about using the camera I
was framed from the bottom frame from
the bottom like this oh this is this is
when I look best like that that's we
need to get a shot I liked a shot yeah
little bit more depth how do I make more
depth that you know what the background
over there is not bad
turn around oh this is nice wait oh my
go ahead there then I go to the wardrobe
department and Mary Clara teaches me how
to dress all in all it's pretty exciting
how I just realized that I got a green
screen behind me you can do anything to
my head I'm moving so you can't mess
with my head Hank thank you for the
lesson in stars and planets I will see
you tomorrow PS nerdfighters there are
only four days left in pizza miss so if
you want my mustachioed face on any of
these items you must order in the next
four days link in the doobly-doo goodbye